[Music]
a
let's talk about our democracy y for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them the tattoo is [__]
red that's right I got
it very first session is a success
yes super excited thank you to all of
you on the team tattoo team tattoo you
came through team tattoo came through
that's right um just tell you a little
story in case you guys didn't know
Friday I went to get my tattoo that's
right I went to get this tattoo right
here on my arm you guys can see the the
microphone there maybe maybe not it's a
good start got a lot more shading to go
but I went to get the tattoo I drove two
and a half hours to Kansas
City got there so excited have all my
[__] ready was ready to live
stream Tony forgot his [__] ID that's
right in the state of Missouri you have
to have an ID to get a tattoo you gotta
have an ID to buy a loaf of
bread and you gotta have an ID to get a
tattoo
so I didn't actually get the tattoo on
Friday we did though how it wasn't a
complete bust it was not a complete bust
so I do want to say that um I got to
meet the artist in live and in person
for the first time which is really cool
his name is Owen and Owen did a
fantastic job with the tattoo but not
only that did a fantastic job after I
[__] up and forgot my
ID because he rescheduled for yesterday
on a Sunday he had his entire day blow
up so really honestly maybe it was like
meant to be that I went in yesterday
because when I went in yesterday um we
were the only ones in the tattoo shop so
uh I do I get bonehead of the weekend
Bon head of the weekend you know if you
go out and you want to buy groceries you
need a picture mhm on a card you need
ID
mhm yeah so you got to have an ID to buy
bread and you definitely got to have ID
to get a tattoo in the state of Missouri
it's it's the it's the law so I did
remember I I did remember my ID
yesterday for that reason now I actually
thought I had my
ID I had that morning I went to the bank
to get the money for the tattoo and I
stuck my ID in my coat and I decided
that coat didn't look very good with
what I had on so I put on a different
coat turns out when I got home the ID
wasn't even in the coat it was in my
truck so what are you gonna do with [__]
gonna do what the [__] you gonna do but
I do appreciate everyone on team tattoo
you guys got to watch uh the tattoo live
and don't worry if you guys want to
still join team tattoo I'm gonna reopen
that fund because I didn't know this but
apparently you can just go and join team
tattoo put any amount of money in team
tattoo it's $5 $10 20 whatever you want
to do um it'll get you in team tattoo
and all that money goes to the artist
because this is a long process you can
see that the tattoo here um with the
microphone right here is where the
phrase is going to go on the tattoo um
but I've got pictures of it uh we did
streams so you'll get access to all the
prior streams so if you join team tattoo
I'll email you all the prior streams and
all that kind of good stuff so you get
all that stuff and you'll be able to go
go to that needs to open a wallet
fr
I I do uh I need to open a wallet fund
uh so that way I can buy myself a wallet
I don't carry a [__] wallet I don't
carry I don't I don't carry a goddamn
wallet so [__] sue me okay sue me for
83 million would
you he lost $83
million 83 me listen I you know it's not
funny what he did to EEG Carroll when he
raped her or when he defamed her right
it's not funny but it's hilarious it's
hilarious to watch the Sheep the
maglites the Cheeto [__] hump nuggets
the Cheeto hump and [__]
nuggets I don't know maybe I'm still a
little out of it the
Cheeto [__] nuggets that's it Cheeto
hump [__] the Cheeto humping [__]
nuggets if and
listen I posted
let's see on Twitter about him losing
$83 million and I think I directed it
towards Tim P because [__] that little
[__] right [__] that little [__] timpool
you know what I mean and they were all
pissed off H like he would actually grab
her or some [__] like that you people
seem a little pissed off that's what he
he
posted no that was a different
one H and the m
the mes got my comments and they're like
oh egene Carol will never see a dime of
that money I'm like what what do you
mean you'll never see a dime of the
money he wants to appeal so he actually
has to give the money over into like an
escrow account so like he has to put up
the 83 million to even appeal the
decision it would be nice if you [__]
idiots could learn how to read you know
what I mean that would be great I mean
honestly we would be in a lot better
shape if the if the Cheeto hump and [__]
nuggets just actually picked up a book
or two learned how to [__]
read and just got with reality here but
that's the point is that they're not in
reality they're not in reality and I
normally don't show you [__] on the
screen during the the a block but here
we're gonna do this um this what Tim P
said eing Carol is a deranged old [__]
well that may be true but she's [__]
rich now oh man she's a rich deranged
old [__] the 18.3 million is in
compensatory damages this thing is has
exploded
[Music]
on it's crazy and and then he's probably
on Wednesday is when the judge is
supposed to make the decision in the
Civil Trial he gonna lose another 400
million keep going [__] keep going
that's a half a billion dollars that he
didn't [__]
have
so [__] him so yeah yeah Tim e Carol
might be a deranged old [__] but she's a
[__] Rich one now she's a [__]
Rich one [__] and the comments were
like oh she'll never see a dime of that
money you're so brainwashed you don't
know what you're talking about Tony from
the maglites like what the [__] go read
[__] go [__] read he has to put up
the $83 million to appeal they're like
he's going to appeal and win
get the [__] out of here he has no
grounds to even appeal but the good news
is when he appeals he has to put up the
money that she gets so basically he's
giving her the money to go appeal [__]
him [__] him and everyone who supports
him and really honestly this this is the
greatest thing ever if you wanna if you
want to understand politics and
elections in this country because I know
Haley Nikki Haley is waiting around for
the 14th Amendment decision right I get
it I get it right because she keeps
saying she's waiting around for South
Carolina but really they're waiting for
the 14th decision which is not going to
go in the favor of Nikki Haley nor is it
going to go in the favor of all these
[__] deranged leftists who have no
clue about who the Supreme Court is and
what the law is and reading the 14th
section three just go [__] read it
and you'll understand go look at the
prior decisions and you'll understand
that they're not going to take him off a
[__] ballot they're not they're not
going to do do it just like they're not
going to give him presidential immunity
either it's it's wild and crazy it's
wild and crazy that we're going to have
all these decisions come in and the
Supreme Court is going to decide to not
give him presidential immunity in the
left like yeah they're so great yay the
Supreme Court and then and then they're
gonna shoot down the [__] 14th
Amendment think you're like oh we hate
them it's rigged like you sound like MAA
okay you sound like [__] MAA just
look look at what the [__] is reality
look at what is possible and what what
we're dealing with here and just just
tether yourself to a little bit of Truth
okay rather you're on the right or the
left quit listen we can't win if we're
just as delusional as they are all right
now what we can do what we can do is
make sure that if it sounds like
delusion we know it's delusion but it's
to [__] with them like the mocker and
[__] [__] you know the mockery is
completely important yeah the
cowbell the cowbell Commandos you know
what I mean this is important on this
end that we just we cause all kinds of
good trouble when we're winking at each
other like like this [__] right here the
whistles
go whistles go
who when when he's calling uh aene Carol
and old derang [__] just concede that to
them you know it's not true right we
know egene Carrol is not a deranged old
[__] I know that you know that we all
[__] know that but seed that fact to
him who gives a [__] rather they think
EEG Carol's derang [__] or not who cares
who cares in the grand scheme of things
but make sure you mock them per
correctly yeah she might be but she's
[__] rich now
[__] that's how we got to do this it's
how we're going to [__] win it's not
standing around complaining about who's
saying what and get it offended over
every little [__] thing cuz could I
be offended by Tim p calling egene Carol
drach gun oh my God what a misogynist oh
it's so offensive he shouldn't have said
that and blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah or should we just [__] mock him
should we just [__] mock him because
that's real that's really what gets them
all heated that's what really gets them
in a [__]
pinch is when we mock the [__] out them
them and they can't do anything but have
their stupid little [__] comebacks
that aren't tied to reality and that's
the important part is to keep them
delusional do you follow me that's part
that's part of the whole thing that's
part of the whole
thing that's part of the whole thing is
to keep them [__] delusional folks
the numbers are not on their side here
this [__] country hates Trump
[__] hates him also [__] hates
anyone who has anything to do with his
dumbass did you watch the Arizona
Republican convention where they [__]
booed Carrie
Lake they [__] booed her ass they
[__] boot her and the reason why is
because she's a [__]
loser and the reason why she's a loser
is because she's with Trump they're
[__] losers
they're
[__] losers cousen Humpin fascist
these people are writing bills in the
states like state of Missouri where they
want to check children's genitalia
before they take a piss they're writing
bills to take away parental consent
about what books they want their kids to
read They're they're criminalizing
Women's Pregnancy and Women's Health
Care and banning the their privacy in
doctor's offices they want to eradicate
certain people in our country our
citizens our neighbors our
friends our fellow humans because they
feel uncomfortable about who they
love are you following what the [__]
they're doing these things are not
popular I don't give a [__] how they
Square them I don't care how they yell
and scream about them I don't care what
they're tweeting about them these things
are not
popular this is not
populism they are pretending that it's
populism rules and what we should do as
the pro-democracy Coalition in operation
go commando is we should do a little bit
of pretending ourselves you know what I
mean we should do a little bit of
pretending just just maybe a little bit
of pretending would be
nice you know like pretend that the
white Christian nationalists are
actually the [__]
threat that we should mock them into
Oblivion that what we should do is make
them so humiliated that they're even
that they're even that they're even
associated with these [__] groups or
these [__] people that they will
crawl back underneath their rocks or
they will boo them out of
conventions we got to drive those wedges
down in between these [__] fascists
and make them fight each other that is
why I advocate for telling Liz Cheney
Chris Christie Adam kininger and Paul
Ryan to [__] off that'll drive a wedge
down in between them if we tell Liz
Cheney to [__] off [__]
you that'll drive a wedge down in
between them because Liz Cheney is gonna
fight Trump no matter what we do or what
we say or how much we praise her we need
those
wedges we not only need Liz Cheney
operating in in synchronization with the
pro democracy Coalition and operation go
commando unbeknownst to her we can tell
her she can go get
[__] because she's a fascist too so we
should pretend a little bit we should
pretend you know what I
mean we should we should really [__]
make sure no matter how much we have to
pretend to win this fight that we do
that because again I've been telling you
the last few weeks there there may not
be anything I wouldn't say
and there may not be anyone that I may
not
offend to save my democracy and to save
this country you can go [__] yourself if
you want to do anything else but that
and that's what we're going to be about
here for the next year we're going to be
about winning this [__] not that goddamn
right the [__] cowbell
Commandos in operation go
commando is going to kick ass and take
[__] names for this democracy and
they are not ignore us they're going to
be pissed off at us I'm telling you
you're going to get a lot of lefties are
going to hate you they like I can't
believe you listen to that [__] I can't
believe you I can't believe you're not
offended by this you need to be
offended you need to [__] be aware
that we gotta win this [__] we gotta win
this election not just the top of the
ticket that shit's gonna be easy it's
gonna be easy to beat grandpa
shitler I mean goddamn [__]
[__] ain't even gonna have any
money and the only money he's got is
what the Russians the
Saudis and his [__] toothless
supporters give
him some people are talking about
Anarchy
princes since we've hearkening back to
the cowbells yes she is gonna be on the
show this week and not just this week
I'm hoping I'm hoping and she cut a clip
of when I was talking about her the
other day I'm hoping we can fullon
recruit her into to operation go
commando and cause all kinds of good
trouble all kinds of good
trouble it's it's
listen they're not going to give up okay
these fascists are not going to stop I
mean Jesus Christ you you see they
remember when they made is such a big
deal that there might have been a little
cocaine in the White House and you
remember that there like oh we found we
found cocaine in the white house we need
a big investigation Hunter Biden's dick
Hunter Biden's dick Hunter Biden's dick
and cocaine you know that they I mean
they're obsessed with it Hunter Biden's
dick and
cocaine and they act they act like it
was a [__] semi- trck load of cocaine
that was found in the Biden wine house
it just a little baggy I mean who
doesn't carry a little baggy of cocaine
around you know what I mean I mean every
so often not all the time time Jesus
Christ what do you think I am some kind
of
beatnick just because I got a tattoo
now just a little bit of coke you know
what I mean I don't think cocaine should
be
criminalized you know just go off on a
tangent here I mean I think that's a
good discussion to have in the country
about you know how we criminalize drugs
and [__] but I don't know if you heard
this speaking of [__] speaking of
[__] drugs maybe I shouldn't call him
Grandpa [__] anymore maybe I should call
him the fent andol fear her holy [__]
did you see did you [__] see how many
drugs they were giving this son of a
[__] God
damn God God
godamn they were [__] pumping this
guy I mean uppers downers lowers uppers
more
middles they're putting him to sleep
keeping him [__]
awake yeah he was he was the fent andol
furer I mean I'm not going to run out of
[__] nicknames if that's what you're
thinking like we're not going to We're
not gonna run out of them you know what
I mean but this guy was taking fentanyl
look fentanyl's bad we need to get all
the fentel out of the country and into
my mouth get in there get in there
fentel I need that fentel baby and the
ketamine o and the morphine oh Baby that
gets me going that's why I can't start
my day till 11 I'm taking so much
[__]
drugs this guy was pounding him man and
I'm not against drug use I'm not against
recreational drug use or really drug use
that you need to I don't know get up in
the morning and pretend to be a
president I
guess but [__] man you're gonna you're
gonna go you're gonna talk about Hunter
Biden being a drug addict when the fent
on fur the only way he operates is
uppers and downers every [__] day
come on man you're GNA talk about h b
drug use that's why I'm saying we don't
need a demonize we don't need to
demonize drug users we really don't it's
kind of it's kind of a shitty thing to
do to to you know to and again is it
offensive [__] I don't know maybe it's
offensive to some people but goddamn it
we're gonna have a reasonable
conversation about something in this
country that we could [__] change
like guns are [__] are are making
sure that people who have addictions get
[__] health care because that's
that's the problems we got most of the
time godamn that's probably 80% of our
[__] homeless problem in this country
is those people have addictions and they
don't have access to health care to help
them with their [__] addiction
man but we got [__] the fentol fear
her preaching to
us when that son of a [__] is
pounding pounding the [__] the
pharmacy I mean come on man what the
[__] we're demonizing addicts like
Hunter Biden acting like they're [__]
National Security threats when the the
the the craziest thing that Hunter Biden
probably did was sniff Coke out of some
hooker's [__] okay yeah it sounds
gross it's crazy but is that a national
security threat Hunter Biden doing some
coke out of
some some escort's ass right is that is
that that bad I don't know maybe it is
maybe it ain't maybe you wouldn't do it
[__] I don't know but come on man don't
we have better issues to [__] deal
with when you're talking about National
Security it's the same [__] with this
[__] border stuff they want to make
this a national security oh it's a
national security threat no you're the
national security threat Jesus Christ
Trump is standing on stage guaranteeing
that his [__] supporters are going to
commit terrorist acts that's what he's
doing that's what he's doing when he
stands on stage like look look look 100%
domestic terrorism is going to happen I
guarantee it I'm going to make sure of
it I'm going to make sure that my people
my people commit terrorism in this
country that's what we're gonna do ah
hail the fentol furer Hail him H the
vent offia
her and then there's GNA be some [__]
trucker Convoy go down I guess I guess
there's a bunch of there's a bunch of
Canadian cucks that are going to go down
to the do the southern border so they're
going to cross the northern border to go
down to the southern border to what
fight the US military is that really
what you're gonna do huh that's your
[__] idea of a good idea Jesus Christ
come up with a worse idea than
that
[__] this is [__] ridiculous man that
we even have to talk about this [__]
these are the stories that are in the
news these are the stories that are in
the news
and it's all because we're in this
stupid [__] up timeline because a
bunch of brainless
idiots think they own this
country you go get [__] you don't own
this country you don't own
us that border the [__] goddamn
imaginary line and people crossing isn't
the problem that's not the [__]
problem the problem is Washington won't
get off their ass and do something about
the way we treat people when they come
here and the way we assimilate
assimilate them into American society
that's the [__] problem all
right enough of the [__] blah blah
blah yakity SCH smacky about the Border
in the wall and the security and blah
blah blah blah blah and they want a
civil
war good go have your Civil
War go [__] with the US military [__]
around find out see what happens go see
see what happens when you [__] around
with the US military try it just like
you did at the [__] Capital where
hundreds of a years sitting in prison
right now with your bare feet on a cold
concrete
floor that's a great idea go to the
border and [__] with the US government
oh yeah brilliant same way with all
these [__] these these [__] cousin
[__] fascists in these governments
like these Governors these 25 Governors
that are going to stand behind tick
stand behind Texas for what it's not
their [__] border to US border you
son of a
[__] that's the [__] United States
of America's border if you like
imaginary lines we want to Define who
those imaginary lines belong to doesn't
belong to
Texas belongs to us that's our [__]
border with our Ally Mexico dummy it's
so crazy to think that Trump brags about
getting the trade deal with Mexico and
all you all the maglites cheap [__] you
know what I mean they're like look the
TVs from Mexico are so good but the
people suck get the [__] out of here
man either you like cheap [__] coming
from Mexico and you'll invite and you'll
invite those people in to come be part
of our country or just come in for a
little bit to [__] I don't know pick
crops in the field because d no goddamn
entitled [__] white person that's
going to do it in this country have you
ever met a [__] white person that
would go work for the wages that they
work for in those fields and pick the
[__] and do the hard work that they do
to pick to pick our food so that we have
[__] Foods on our plate we throw away
half that [__] food that's what we
think about it we throw away that [__]
because oh God it's past a certain date
it's still looks good tastes good still
is good but we'll throw that [__] away
because we're entitled white people
[__] out of here with this [__] it's
not of this nonsense just call it like
we see it just say
it sick and tired of people not just
saying what needs to be
said and it's foolish to think that we
can't beat Trump we can't beat the fent
andol
furer grantpa shitler goddamn the
nicknames just get better and better and
better right the fent all fear
her go spread that [__] around the
internet that'll [__] piss them off
these Cheeto humping [__] nuggets
that'll piss them off you know the other
thing that pisses them off is a tattoo
like this and I want to talk about it
one more time let me let me get you
there's a good look for people who
haven't seen it yet now again the
outline down here isn't complete and the
shading isn't complete that's what we're
going to we're going to finish more more
shading on February
17th so if you want to join team tattoo
to see those previous live streams and
the ones that are happen in February I'm
going to do one tonight too tonight I'm
going to do a Q&A last night I didn't
have time uh to do my last stream I had
to go visit a friend in the hospital um
in Kansas City so I didn't get a chance
to do my last stream so we're going to
do a stream tonight A Q&A uh and and if
you want to get access to that Q&A go to
teen tattoo fund I know it says it's
closed but if you just put five 10
whatever you're going to get access to
all those streams all that content
you'll get access to all of it and we'll
be I'm going to be releasing some videos
and stuff to the public uh some shorts
and stuff of the tattoos so you can see
kind of the process and that way if you
want to join in on live streams because
this thing is going to be a process it's
not just a one-time deal like it's going
to be a whole sleeve um eventually but
we're gonna work appointment by
appointment a session by session you
guys are going to get to see the tattoo
you're going to get to know Owen the um
the artist he's [__] fantastic
[__] I am so [__] happy that I
picked Owen oh my God and if you guys
haven't went and looked at his Instagram
you should um I I'll probably post that
later on uh maybe on patreon so go join
patreon for free but stick around after
this maybe we'll grift a little bit
let's grift are you hungry for some
pizza don't go anywhere we'll be right
back we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you ready for best pizza of
Life bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things need delivery
pizzas come fast knock knock who's there
pizza magic eat pepperoni hug spot Pizza
your tummy say thank you your mouth say
m pepperoni hug spot it's like family
but with more
cheese patch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thony Michaels we're back to
the king of brilliant this is the Tony
Michaels
podcast
[Music]
so Trump grabbed her by the [__] but
she's got him by the [__] balls folks
that's right she's got him by the
balls I'm glad you join me every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for two
full hours two full hours you're here
every single weekday and I broadcast
from the antifa headquarters in Kami
fall
Missouri because that's what pisses them
off and our special sponsor today let's
see who is our special sponsor today oh
yes speaking of cowbells in good trouble
we have our special sponsors Gras ice
cream shop granda's ice cream shop brand
new
flavor God damn
it it's Monday what do you want from me
what do you want from me what do you
want from me here we go here it is there
we go all granta's ice cream shop the
brand new favor is chocolate cowbell
chocolate get your brand new flavor and
granda's ice cream shop the chocolate
cowbell flavor it terrifies fascist they
won't even go near an Grand defa's ice
cream shop it's so scary it's so scary
it's so scary oh no oh no Granda Grand
TAA ice cream cowbells oh no it really
kills the um the fascist really kills
the fashes speaking of that a lot of
people are saying great tattoo great
tattoo nice ink nice ink very cool very
cool thank you it is a great tattoo and
it's going to get better and better as
he as he adds more shading and gets gets
in there and again if you want um here's
the actual gri if you if you want to get
in on team tattoo I would recommend you
you get in um going by going to the Tony
michaels.com click on team tattoo fund
you put any amount in there however much
you want to contribute um and you're
going to get ACC to live streams uh I'll
email pictures as it happens we'll be
having a live stream tonight for Q&A one
of the questions is is where where let
me see where on the tattoo is the phrase
this machine kills fascism gonna go I'll
tell you tonight that during the Q&A
I'll show it to you I'm gonna actually
have a picture of it and I'll send you
guys a picture of it because frankly now
that I've got the tattoo and we've got
the design you guys could go take this
and get this same tattoo tattooed on you
if you wanted so go join team tattoo if
you want to do that just $5 $10 whatever
you want to contribute get you part of
Team tattoo all that money that you put
in team tattoo is going to go to Owen
the artist eventually uh Jane do said
did it hurt did it hurt find out tonight
on the
Q&A I I don't I don't want to do too
much tattoo talk because team tattoo U
they've um they they've been there from
the very beginning there was so many of
them on the live stream when we were
live because I live stream the tattoo at
the process several times I didn't get
to do the live stream last night in the
followup that's why I'm going to do a
Q&A follow-up tonight with Team tattoo
where they can ask any questions about
the tattoo I'm gonna show them the
design I'm gonna show them where the
phrase this machine kills fascism is
going to be on that design so it's gonna
be really cool
um that that's a big tattoo Oh I thought
you were saying like you know zero days
big step fan that's a big tattoo that's
a big tattoo um so it's actually it's
gonna be a full sleeve that's what it'll
be eventually so and we'll talk more
about that tonight and I'll show you
some more of the design on other parts
of the arm if you and I'll show you that
I'll show you some of them pictures and
stuff that I've got uh of design and
ideas um so you guys can tell me what
you like what you don't
like uh I meant I don't want one that
big she didn't want the big one
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy all right um
so Donald Trump did say that he
guarantees that he his supporters are
going to commit domestic terrorist acts
now he didn't say it exactly like that
so you know I know a lot of people are
going to get mad at me they're like he
didn't say it exactly like that I don't
give a [__] listen this is the whole
point this is what I'm trying to tell
you [__] is we need to mock
them and yeah we need to so what if we
[__] pretend a little bit so what if
we [__] pretend a little
bit right I mean they're always [__]
pretending and if we can pretend in
unison we'll get them all [__] fired
up right think about it think about it
for a second right if we if we convince
if we
convince the domestic terrorist who want
to commit domestic terrorism that giving
them a cat call right and they're like
no no no no no that's not I mean it's
kind I mean yeah we want to commit
terrorism that's not really what I mean
we want toy he's given us orders let
them get caught in that [__] trap see
that's the best part about this all is
is we gotta come at this with the white
Christian nationalism we gotta [__]
take this [__] out of our governments
that's the problem that we're actually
having is that we don't don't have two
parties in this country that believes in
democracy they don't one party wants a
Theocratic monarchy and they want this
guy to be their [__] dict
taster I'm just not down with that I'm
not I'm not I'm never going to be down
with that kind of [__] any of that kind
of
talk where your religion and your
nationalism wants to make this guy the
king [__] you you can go [__] yourself
okay hard too really [__] hard really
[__] hard go take some goddamn fentol
with the fentol fear her and take it
take it and stick that that fascist [__]
where the sun don't shine okay I don't
give a
[__] and I ain't G to L up either and I
ain't G to stop saying it that way
either I don't give a [__] who gets
offended or why they get offended I
don't give a [__] don't [__] yourself it
is not time to [__] light glove this
this the Grant Paul shitler listen to
this [__] and there's a 100% chance that
there will be a major terrorist attack
in the United States or many attacks
maybe maybe because what's happened
maybe there'll be many attacks maybe
just maybe I'll tell my supporters to
commit manyi attack [__] you [__] you go
to hell you little
[__] bring that [__] on let's have at
it if you want to do this that way fine
whatever I mean no one wants no one
wants to you
know have this snowball from Hell his
[__] [__]
here try to get try to get [__] his
toothless meal Team Six to commit
violence
right no one wants that we don't want to
have to do that kind of [__] but goddamn
we will if we have
to they act like they act like that [__]
hasn't happened before and we won't
stand up for
ourselves I mean I would much rather I
would much rather do this at The Ballot
Box that's the way that democracies
handle this [__] that's the way that our
Coalition should handle this
[__] but if that's how he wants to do it
because he's gonna be the [__]
nominee I don't know if you noticed that
[__] I don't know if you [__] noticed
that [__] he's definitely going to be
the [__]
nominee he like look look I know the RNC
said that they want me to be king Maga
and it was my idea but it totally wasn't
my idea and by me saying it wasn't my
idea it's totally admitting that it's my
idea the [__] what kind of drugs is the
fentol furer
on to think that we're not going to
[__] know that [__] when he says it
Out Loud come on and not to know what
what what he's saying here over the last
three years when I'm and there's a 100%
chance that there will be a major
terrorist attack in the United States or
many attacks maybe many attacks maybe
maybe just maybe maybe you mean like the
one on January six you mean like that
one like that terrorist
attack mean like that one
hostages maybe that one is that the one
you're talking
about we're all them [__] domestic
terrorist went to the capital and you
like hey hey you know what it' be cool
you know would be cool if you went and
overthrow the government and made me
King go down to the capital and do that
I'm your I'm your fent all
furer here here's some fent
all listen to it again maybe I'm wrong
but listen and there's a 100% chance
that there will be a major terrorist
attack
in the United States or many attacks
maybe many attacks maybe maybe let me
show you the [__] idiots that are
going to commit these attacks though
because that's really the thing that's
the funny
part oh my God that's the [__] funny
part the me Team Six is who I'm talking
about you seen these [__] I
showed this video
before and but it didn't have the nice
music um put to it
um let me let me show you these [__]
idiots here here here's the one here's
the the guys that are going to go down
to the border and [__] with the US
military this guy right
[Music]
here this is who they're going to
handle
[Music]
golden
Mand that's right the golden fandos are
going to go down to the
Border what do you want for
me I get to make this
[__]
watching this
guy this is who we're supposed to be
scared
of this is the reason why January 6
didn't go over so
well bunch of fat Stooges going down to
the [__] border January 6
hostages here's another one here you go
this is this is this is another image of
one of the [__] Golden Coral
Commandos the meal Team Six look at this
guy this guy's GNA he's GNA he gonna
fight for
America oh man
godamn
baby God
damn this is the
people taking sexy
selfies of their package here and I'm
not talking about the dick on this guy
I'm talking about the
Dunlap you know this is where this is
what happens when your belly done lapped
over your belt I used to have one I used
to have a done laap I used to not be
able to see my [__] dick I was so fat
like this like this fat [__] keto
humping [__]
nugget
whoops
whoops that's who that's who we're
that's who's gonna [__] that is who's
going to take their country back and
they think we're and they think we're
going to be afraid I I think we'll be
all
right I I think will be okay all right
and this is the proper mockery okay and
I and I know I know a lot of people
don't like the mockery but we really
need to lean into it and
honestly since they've normalized it
that's not our [__] problem right the
right is normalized this kind of [__] so
what are you gonna do and James Carville
said it best in a video over the weekend
speaking of the Commandos we need to get
operation go commando have you guys been
tagging James Carville you need to go
tag him on social media tell him to come
talk to me tell him to come talk to the
rustling ball the left that's what you
need to do I guarantee you if James
Carville hears there's some dude out
there who don't give a [__] about [__]
who's who's
[__] whose motto is [__]
him he runs around talking about the the
the fentanyl furer now I'd love to get
James Carville to say the Fentanyl furer
and he'll mock any of these fascists who
doesn't care even even if one's in a
wheelchair he'll definitely definitely
mock the roller Nazi they see me
rolling they
hating I'm rideing fascist I'm gonna
rideing fascist he's gonna rideing
fascist what do you want from me this is
the kind of [__] we need to
do and I know like sometimes it feels
gross but [__]
them there's a hell of a lot more at
stake than to stand around and seeing if
we're gonna offend a bunch of leftist oh
you can't say that about them oh man
that makes you just as bad as them well
[__] me what do you mean just as bad as
them they want to destroy your democracy
and they're hellbent on it they don't
give a [__] illegals over the
wall what are you talking about man they
want to [__] exterminate people they
want to take away women's [__] rights
to healthcare they want to ban their
privacy they want to take away their
[__] vote if you want to know the
God's honest truth that's what they're
coming for
next they don't want the lgbtq community
to be out in public because it makes
them feel uncomfortable well [__] you
I'm done with this snowflake [__] I
don't care who it comes from I don't
care who's not willing to say what needs
to be said I like this nickname too
Aderall
Adolf Aderall off the fentol
furer oh my
God this is why I love the [__]
fam this is why I love the [__]
fam because you guys understand the
stakes and you guys understand how to
weaponize
mockery you've always understood it
that's the reason why this show is so
[__] entertaining in the first place
it ain't just because of
me
you I mean most people come here in the
chat just to watch the chat because of
the crazy [__] that's said in the chat
and forget about the guy on the
mic this is a [__] community of
[__] okay that's what this
is and it's all aimed to save our
[__] democracy every single ounce of
[__] that we do from here on
out is to make sure the Democracy stands
tomorrow and the next day and the day
after that and the day after that I
don't give a [__] what we have to say
what we have to do how we have to mock
them I don't give a
[__] and I'm with you 100% all the
way 100% And if you're if you're looking
for a [__] place that you can save
your democracy and not give a [__] about
what anyone [__] is offended by this
is the [__] place right
here an operation go commando is in full
[__]
Force full force
I mean look at this [__] look at this
kind of
mockery posting this on the sidewalk
writing this on the sidewalk in front of
Trump
Tower 83.3 million hahaa keep talking
loser you [__]
loser this is a perfect meme right here
and it's in real life someone went and
wrote that [__] on the
sidewalk and if we got to use a to mock
this son of a [__] good A lot of people
have been
bitching about my AI Trump
videos and I really don't give a
[__] I really don't give a [__] I don't
give a [__] anymore go for it trumpy
listen hey MAA it is me your favorite
fraud guess what I'm gonna need you to
band together to make America great
again I don't know if you heard but King
Maga here just lost 83 million and and I
am close to losing another 400 million
so America is hurting for donations and
needs to help pay for all my losing hey
M because that's that's what they're
gonna do the only way he's gonna be able
to for this 83 million and then God
knows it's probably going to be four
or500
million out of New York the Civil Trial
that he committed fraud on the state of
New York with the Trump
organization
you know you know he's going to lose a
bunch of money there too but who's going
to pay for it meal Team
Six the Cheeto [__] H the Cheeto
humping [__] nuggets Cheeto humping [__]
nugget that's it right there nutty and
[__] squirrel turds that they're
gonna [__] back this son of a
[__] and pay for his legal woses but
folks hey MAA it is me your favorite
fraud get this
fraud when MAA gives him and he uses
maa's money or whoever's money I don't
give a [__] whose money it is because it
ain't gonna be his money because he
ain't got it he ain't got that you think
he's got [__] 600
million you think this [__] has
$600
million come on man no one who has $600
million laying around begs his [__]
supporters for $5
donations to sell them Trump pocket
knives I ain't [__] you I get the
emails too I get his campaign email so I
can see his
Griff he's trying to sell [__] Trump
pocket knives that they're going to use
I guess in the Civil War some
[__] I don't
know fting off your her with my trump
pocket knife I
guess swice it's like a it's like a
Swiss Maga knife you know what I mean
maybe not
Swiss I I'm not you know I don't care if
to offend people but goddamn it's pretty
offensive to the Swiss isn't
[Laughter]
it every time Donald Trump wants to
insult Jean Carol he's gonna have to
write a $40 million check for each
[Music]
sentence each
sentence iby keeps talking iby talks his
way into bankruptcy again I hope he
keeps talking so much that Maga has to
give him so much money this year that
they can't sping a single single [__]
dime on his campaign once he gets the
nomination think about that for a second
that's the beautiful part about this and
some people are gonna say oh Tony yeah
that's why they did it is to take away
his money so he can't run for president
well he can go [__]
himself [__] him honestly this is way
better this is way better that he has to
keep spending [__] mountains of money
defending his stupid [__] mouth
because he can't keep it shut he's got
the right to remain silent he ain't got
the [__]
ability I mean [__] I got the right to
remain sent I ain't got the [__]
ability I do not have the I swear to God
I do not have the ability to keep quiet
I just don't so I know how it feels
right and someday might come back to
haunt
me but I think my cause is a little
better right like my cause for democracy
and furthering that right that idea and
giving democracy to the next [__]
generation and the generation after that
and generation after that I think it's a
little better
cause than just keeping this guy out of
jail one
dude and I won't shut the [__]
up Crystal's right here on Facebook Tony
can't shut the [__] up no I can't I
can't shut the [__] up and I
won't the whole point of this enormous
damage unprecedented damage is to tell
Donald Trump to shut
[Music]
up it is to tell him to shut the [__] up
but he won't so he's just gonna have to
keep paying and as long as Maga keeps
giving him money he's Gonna Keep keep
talking like so I give him your [__]
money go broke I whatever [__] I don't
care honestly if the entire Nazi
Republican base the white Christian
nationalists gather up all their money
and give it all to Trump so egene Caroll
gets it are we really gonna be [__] are
we really are we really gonna be upset
that egene Caroll gets all that
money that she gets all the Maga I mean
you know I like EEG Carroll
right and I I think I think the idea
that he'll raise a bunch of maa's money
just to give it to her [__] yeah [__]
yeah baby I bet EEG Carol is gonna share
that [__] a hell of a lot better than
maer or Trump
will I think that's where this is
going I think that's where this is going
he just gonna keep digging a hole and
he's gonna keep asking MAA for money
listen to him hey Maga it is me your
favorite fraud guess what I'm gonna need
you to band together to make America
great again I don't know if you heard
but King Maga here just lost 83 million
and I am close to losing another 400
million so America is hurting for
donations and needs to help pay for all
my
losing all his losing because he's gonna
keep losing and keep losing and keep
yeah I I know that this is AI and it's
not real I mean maybe it is maybe it is
maybe it is good maybe it is
[Music]
real
you [__] decide right and really
honestly let the maglites decide because
even though this is AI this is totally
how he feels right this is totally how
he feels he totally is sitting there
thinking when that $83 million verdict
came in he was thinking I'm gonna have
my I'm gonna have my [__] the meal
Team Six pay for this I'm gonna have the
Golden Coral Commandos pay for
this I mean they'll go to the border and
commit violence they'll go to the
capital and try to overturn the
government for me why wouldn't they give
me a little bit of scratch to pay EG
Carol 83 million
bucks so it might be AI it might be AI
but it's the [__]
truth it's the [__]
truth and don't be mad at me because
we're just using a little a little
machine that sounds like Trump to tell
his
truth [__] him
[__] them [__] them [__] him this is
proper mockery this is how we
win because really this confuses the
[__] out of Maga
right this confuses the [__] out of them
because they're like oh no Tony this
ain't
real this is AI and then we're like okay
yeah I bet it's
AI pretend just pretend just a little
bit just a little bit I mean it's just a
little pretending it's not really lying
I mean kind of but [__]
him [__] him you think we're going to
win you think we're going to win by not
pretending a little
bit pretending just to get underneath
their [__] skin just get them to lose
their minds I mean we got a shake we got
to shake this country loose man did you
see how these [__] these fascists
lost their minds over Taylor Swift over
the weekend because the Chiefs
won the Kansas City Chiefs of football
team listen to me a football team one
and it ain't I mean I'm not saying
Taylor Swift is good or bad at sucking
dick I have no idea she may not even do
that that may be a thing that she does
not consent to I don't know but some
people might argue that's the reason why
Travis Kelce did such a great
job because she did a great job but
that's all nonsense man that's all
nonsense to act like Taylor Swift had
some sort of input to the outcome of a
football game game you people have lost
your minds you lost your goddamn
minds but you know what I don't give a
[__] lean into do
it lean into do it lean into it put
those Taylor Swift [__] memes out
everywhere and talk about Taylor Swift
anytime you can because that's another
fact speaking of rich women like een
Carol eege Carol is [__] dripping
dripping in the money [__] guess who's
really [__] Rich too super [__]
Rich way richer than Travis Kelce or
Donald Trump or ever dream of being way
more
famous and has actual [__] fans who
like her for [__] she actually did not
some
lie is Taylor
Swift she's [__]
loaded holy
[__] so get out there and get in these
[__]
faces get their faces about Taylor Swift
call yourself the Swifty even if you've
never listened to a Goddamn song pretend
pretend hell go look up some lyrics and
just start dropping Taylor Swift lyrics
in comment
sections where a bunch of Nazis are on
Twitter or Facebook or Instagram who
gives a [__] where it's at just go [__]
with them
just go [__] with
them just grab I I don't know just go
Google Taylor Swift lyrics and just grab
little lyrics and just post them
randomly and just see what these [__]
do the loser
Minds CA is it a good thing that Taylor
Swift is the news no in reality it isn't
but hey we might as well take advantage
of it we might as well we weaponize It
For The Ballot Box and the turnout
because that's really that's really what
we need to focus on with this
mockery because that's how we're going
to win these down ballot races right I
mean if you want a [__] master class
and how to do this [__] we're GNA get
one soon my friend Dr Rachel boffer has
got a book coming out how hit them where
it hurts and how to beat these
[__] at their own goddamn game
these Republicans the way they these
right-wingers have been doing it they've
been doing it correctly they just been
doing it for the wrong [__] ends
their means are for [__] fascism not
for
democracy and that's all we got to do is
just do the same [__] that works in
politics and in elections and narrative
and messaging and gets the country to
pay the [__] attention to make the right
goddamn decision at the right goddamn
time because that's really the the the
whole point is we got to get people to
make the right decision at the right
time and it's so it's so
important it's so important that we get
them red up because there's
no there's no chuckle [__] louder than a
goddamn cousin [__] fascist is there
Cheeto humping fucknugget oh my God they
get so [__] bent out of shape they
lose their minds they yell and scream
and they say the quiet part out loud
when they start doing that
[__] because they get [__]
desperate they get
desperate I mean look at this outside
the courtroom this [__] look at this
look at this set of dsls outside the
courtroom I mean goddamn they still have
Dy dried up dick Lube all over
him after she's been doing doing
whatever I don't know out of her
whatever yeah that's right Tony you
can't say that I don't give a I can say
anything I [__] want and I will say
anything I want to save democracy by God
and if I got to stand here and make fun
of how this [__] piece of sludge was
standing outside the courtroom whining
pissing and moaning about how Trump
defamed EJ and Carroll and a [__]
jury said no you can't do that [__] now
pay
up pay up [__]
83.3
million
8 83
million pay up [__] Twisted we are
seeing a violation of our justice system
ladies and
gentlemen you are not allowed to be
stripped of every defense that you have
blah blah blah yakity schack you are not
allowed to be told that you can't bring
it up and imagine a point where a judge
tells the lawyer before your client the
former president of the United States
the leading candidate and obvious n
nominee for the Republican party before
he takes the stand to defend himself
Miss habba tell me the questions you're
going to ask in open court and tell me
exactly what he's going to respond and
then edited my questions
Ed we're the victims boo [__]
who where where where where listen
dumbass you're in a defamation trial
you're on trial for defamation and not
only that you've been found to defame
her
[__] it's already been decided that you
[__] defamed her so what the judge is
not going to allow you to do which he is
entitled to That Power by the way is not
let you continue to defame her you [__]
trunt you [__] you [__] gutless
[__]
[__] with your dick sucking lips and
your [__] your plastic
surgery your plastic pretty that you got
you need to get a [__] plastic brain
maybe maybe invest in a [__] a
procedure where they'll transplant a
[__]
brain do it goddamn I bet I bet I bet we
would do a [__] fundraiser for Alina
Hama to get a [__] brain
transplant the judge is not going to
allow
you to [__] defame her in C in an
open in his open courtroom after he's
been found to defame
her while they're trying to decide how
much [__] money he's going to have to
pay because he did that [__]
after he [__] raped her and then
defamed her you pile of [__] trash
and now you're whining and complaining
oh he doesn't have the First Amendment
right he's out there saying the [__]
he's saying it no one's [__] putting
a gag over him he's allowed to say he's
just gotta pay $40 million every time he
[__] says it so keep going keep
saying it keep paying if you want to pay
the response he was allowed to give and
guess what my client did he took the
stand he abided by the rules of this
corrupt system that I have seen yeah we
will immediately appeal we will set
aside that ridiculous jury and I just
want to remind you all of one thing we
continue with President Trump to fight
for everybody's First Amendment right to
speak their First Amendment right to
speak listen in a courtroom I don't know
if she knows this I don't know if she
knows this in a courtroom especially in
a civil courtroom where you've been
found to defame someone because you're
saying weird ass [__] about someone that
is that is causing damages you don't
have a First Amendment
right you you listen listen to me listen
to me you do not have a First Amendment
right in a federal courtroom you don't
you don't have the right to say whatever
you want to say when you want to say it
if you want to try it go commit a
federal crime make sure that you alert
the authorities to that federal crime or
just defame someone like majorly and get
inside of a federal
courtroom and just why I listen I I know
I've been in a federal courtroom I've
been a defendant in a federal courtroom
it's not [__] fun it's not fun at all
because you don't get to say anything
you want I mean you can like you can
stand up you can start talking and just
start yelling and
screaming right you know what I mean but
they ain't gonna give a [__] they'll
just detain you
you do
not have the First Amendment right to
say whatever you want inside of a
federal courtroom that is not a
thing it's not a thing it doesn't say in
the first amendment that former presid
it says right there right there in the
First Amendment I'm pretty sure I read
it excuse me I read it I read it it says
it says former presidents especially
ones whose dick looks like a Cheeto
whose dick looks like a Cheeto
gets to have and say anything they want
in a federal courtroom no matter what no
matter what that's their First Amendment
right it doesn't say that
[__] just like these [__] boneheads
who think that you can just say anything
and everything you want whenever you
want you can get away with it no there's
always consequences to your speech even
if you have the First Amendment right
which Donald Trump can go out and he can
keep defaming egene Carroll he
technically has has the right to keep
defaming her he'll have to suffer the
[__] consequence you know what I
mean he'll have to suffer the [__]
consequence of having to payer so I mean
def Fame away man I [__] I'm hoping that
he keeps defaming her I hope
so I want him to lose [__] everything
every goddamn last dime every [__]
blade of grass on every Golf Course that
has his [__] name on
it every [__] inch of concrete and
bricks that has buildings with his
[__] I want him to lose it all all of
it all of it [__]
him [__] him so yeah go use your First
Amendment right get in front of a
microphone start defaming her keep doing
it keep going what do I give a
[__] yes I want him to [__] go
completely [__] bankrupt where he's
Broker Than a goddamn joke [__]
him I mean Jesus Christ he's standing on
stage trying to
direct the Golden Crown Commandos meal
Team
Six these [__] Trump humping [__]
nuggets to go down to the
Border even and they're getting a
Canadian trucker C maybe we'll do
something on this this Canadian truckers
Convoy thing I think they're having
another Convoy where there's a bunch of
Canadian cucks a bunch of Canadian Maga
I don't know why anyone in Canada would
[__] buy into Maga I mean think of I
mean think how dumb it is here in
America right think about this like
you're like good Lord you're still
wearing a trump hat you're still flying
a manga flag how [__] stupid are you
and then if you go up to Canada and they
got MAA what the [__] what what the [__]
are you talking about man Canadians are
MAA that didn't make a goddamn bit of
sense does it Jesus [__] Christ I
mean it just shows you that this
stupidity doesn't have a boundary you
know what I mean like it do have a b
there's no there's no borderline for for
stupidity especially in a world with
social media you know what I
mean ah don't anyone's from CA Canada I
I'm not I'm not I'm not saying that you
are with them or that because can I'm
just saying you know there's stupid ass
[__] in Canada
too there's stupid ass [__] in
Mexico I'm sure in any country really
any state any [__] group of people
you got a group of people and human
beings gathered up there's going to be
some dumb ones in the
mix without enough brain cells to rub
together that need a [__] brain
transplant like Alina Haba she needs to
spend a little less money hey Alina you
need to spend a little less money on the
dsls and get you a brain that's the next
procedure you need to have lay down the
old lips and the [__] whatever the
botox in the face couple times maybe you
can afford get you a [__] brain I
don't know do they do brain transplants
I'm sure we're close to that AR we
aren't we close to that speaking of
another [__] Trump humping [__]
nugget Cheeto humping [__] nugget
humping [__]
nuggets that needs a brain transplant is
the South Dakota
governor Christy
gnome why do they all look the same they
all got these dsls they all look like
they've had [__]
Botox why do they all look like this man
every single last one of these
[__]
you notice that they got to look to him
just wearing the American flag hat cuz
she American she's American even though
she doesn't know [__] about America that
a goddamn thing does this [__] know
about America listen to this [__] that
she said on Fox news about Texas and the
13 colonies uh Texas and those 13
Original Colonies would have never
signed the treaty that formed the first
Constitution of the United States if
they didn't think that their right to
protect themselves and defend their own
people was protected wh what what did
you see the look on his face watch the
look on his face right about there who
well well well well well well what the
[__] did you just say that's the dumbest
[__] I've heard all day that's what that
look is what what you say what' you say
you see
that what the [__] what did she just say
let's listen Texas and the 13 original
colonies never signed the treaty that
formed the first Constitution of the
United States if they
did I'm GNA give you a clue here I want
to give you a
clue let me give you a clue
[Laughter]
Texas oh [__] when the 13 colonies
signed that [__] okay all right when the
13 colonies signed that [__] originally
Texas was
[Laughter]
Mexico oh this stupid [__]
[__] and a lot of people are like hey
hey Christy gnome Texas wasn't part of
the 13 counties yeah but not only was it
not part of the [__] 13 it was it was
[__] Mexico you dumb [__] are you
[__] kidding me what the [__] are you
talking about defend itself like
literally she is saying the opposite of
what would have happened because if
Texas would have been Texas at at the
time of the 13 colonies the [__]
Mexicans that lived in Texas cuz it was
[__]
Mexico you [__]
stupid oh my God these [__] Tweeds
man and I know I know a lot of people I
know a lot of people want to harp on the
13 colonies and Texas wasn't the 13
colony but that's not that's not the
that's not the real Point here because
it absolutely her [__] vision of of
History this this trumped up [__] of
History you know what I mean no pun in
maybe there's pun intended I don't
know Jesus
Christ Texas was [__]
Mexico you
dumbass Jesus [__] so in all reality and
and and Mexico was stolen Texas was
stolen from Mexico by us
and and and and you governor of South
Dakota who sounds more Canadian than you
do American I'm just saying you the more
North you go up the more they sound like
Canucks you know what I mean I'm not
trying to offend I'm okay maybe I'm
trying to may I'm trying to Mr Canada
he's not offended by much he says
education is key folks stay in
school I don't know like she's like yeah
this will sound great this will sound
awesome if I say
Texas wouldn't have signed the
treaty let listen to it again listen to
what she says and watch his response
when she gets to the dumb part Texas and
those 13 Original Colonies would have
never signed the treaty that formed the
first Constitution of the United States
if they didn't think that their right to
protect themselves and defend their own
people was
protected they fight to defend
themselves and protect their own people
Texas was
Mexico yeah treaty that's the other
thing treaty what the [__] are you
talking about treaty that ain't a
treaty oh it's just I the stupidity is
just it knows no
bounds and Democrats are standing around
like well what are we gonna do what
we're going to do is we're going to mock
the [__] out of these people and we're g
to get the country to pay attention to
this [__]
and when they pay attention this [__] no
matter how we got to do it even if we
got to talk about Taylor Swift [__] even
if you got to pretend like yeah it's a
whole antifa plan the whole Taylor Swift
thing like she has she has weekly antifa
meetings that we it's a zoom meeting
with all the swifties it's a Swifty Zoom
meeting on
Sundays okay it's a Swifty Zoom meeting
on Sundays where Taylor Swift tells us
all the plans that an Diva has to take
over the country a duh don't you [__]
know that good Lord we we we make sure
every every [__] week to have cookies
and Grand teas ice cream this week it's
chocolate cowbell is the
flavor at the at the Sunday Swifty
Taylor
meeting duh everyone [__] knows that
a little bit of pretending goes a long
way
okay and it makes sure it makes sure
that
we it make sure that we save our
democracy because if it takes us talking
about Taylor Swift and leaning into the
Taylor Swift thing for these [__]
boneheads to pay attention and I'm not
talking about
Maga I'm not talking about
Maga I'm actually talking about just
average people in
America if it takes that to [__] pay
attention then fine whatever let's do
that um and speaking of pay attention
Joy Leaf um made sure
to heed this call you remember this
[__] this Tweed last week with this
little dick energy with this big gun uh
oh Tiny Dick
Energy this is the type of [__] I'm
talking about spread this [__] around
the
internet spread it around the [__]
internet yeah okay it doesn't feel like
it makes a difference but when we mock
every single one of these fools and keep
mocking them trust me it's G to work
it's going to work and every one of you
out there have a voice every one of you
out there have this account or that
account
right operation go commando is in in
full force and we should keep it in full
force I mean I showed you last
week um prince princess
Anarchy on Twitter where she was [__]
with Peter Navaro holy actual [__]
you talk about some you talk about some
[__] [__] this is
it she's doing it in real life and she's
doing the work but the thing is she
creates this content we spread it around
and we make sure everyone sees that this
[__] lawyer assaulted her because she
was holding a sign with marker on it oh
boohoo ringing a cow bell and blowing a
whistle so yeah
yeah it it's it's going to be a
process but we're going to make it there
I'm very confident I'm very
optimistic the reason why is because you
got this kind of [__] this kind of truth
that
happens Tim P says Biden is a
Nazi and then a Nick fentz supporter a
Nick fentz
supporter says no he's not if he was we
would be supporting him don't respect
the space or whatever like man it is it
is stressful I was just talking about
how people come in here and they just
Vape despite we have like uh I it's it's
wild dude it's it's absolutely [__]
wild Tim P Biden's a Nazi and the Nazis
are like no he's not we would support
him if he was a na
dummy and titim pull doesn't even know
that those are his listeners well maybe
he does May he doesn't that know he's
kind of a [__] idiot I mean maybe
that's what he he he uses the [__]
beanie for is to cover up that he needs
a brain transplant
too I don't
know but it sure is a cell phone when
you're like bid's a
Nazi Nazis who support your show and
support your candidate are like no he's
not if he was the Nazi we would be for
Biden
dummy
he's not the Nazi we're the Nazis you're
a Nazi dummy you should know this you
are you are
one tempool a [__] idiot but let him
keep going with this stuff keep posting
this stupid [__] where you think Biden
is a
fascist and you don't know what fascism
means fine good [__]
you
maybe this kind of honesty from the
right to the right is the kind of [__]
we need to wake people up in this
country because that's the problem it
isn't it isn't the [__] the the
12% of people in this country that are
frothing at the mouth for a fentol fear
her okay that's not the problem it
really isn't right I mean they're loud
and they're obnoxious and they're
[__] annoying and they say some vile
[__] right and more importantly they
have vile [__] ideas that they want
to act on right that's like the most
important
thing they have the the nastiest vest
[__] ideas on the planet and they
want to act on it they want to legislate
those plans and force us make us to be
under their rule under their thumb under
their theocrat
monarchy under their fascist Reign no
not going to happen the fourth Reich is
not going to be in America that is not
where the fourth Reich is GNA be okay
you can go [__]
yourself but goddamn we need to wake up
the part of
America that doesn't know about this
[__] trust me there is a [__] hell of
a lot of people out there that have no
idea there's a goddamn bill in Missouri
that is being pushed by the Nazi
Republicans that's right right they're
Nazi and they're groomers they're
[__] molesters they want to pass a
bill where they can molest have school
administration and School faculty be
able to molest children because they
question their genitalia when they go
take a piss well [__] that [__] not
gonna happen no [__] no you're not
taking my parental consent away and you
see that's how they're doing it they're
like oh yeah dicks dicks with your
chicks with dicks we need to take
parental consent away what are you
talking about fool we're not going to
stand around let you take our parental
consent
away hell
no hell no we're
not that ain't the [__] kind of [__]
we're gonna
do what we're GNA do is we're g to stand
back we're going to mock you we're going
to make sure everyone knows the vile
[__] that you want to do we're going to
mock that vile [__] that you want to do
we're going to mock you for wanting that
vile
[__] and maybe you'll be ashamed maybe
you'll be ashamed maybe you won't but
when you're not ashamed of it now we
know who you really
are we know what kind of [__] America
First
Nazi cousin [__]
fascist white Christian nationalist that
you are and we will boo you and we will
boo you so hard that your party will
start to boo you the people who used to
support you will start to boo you will
start to mock you will start to make a
mockery of your ideas and your ideology
that you want some dictator you want
some King you want to tell people what
religion they got to be you go [__]
yourself just like Carrie Lake can go
[__] herself hell they were booing her
at the goddamn Republican National
Convention in Arizona listen to this
[__] we don't agree on everything but
one thing we do agree on is the
elections in Arizona are a corrup
mess can we agree that our elections are
a mess in Arizona
you okay I love it boo [__] you go [__]
yourself that's
great and they're gonna nominate that
stupid ass for US Senate
good good you should be
excited that Carrie Lake might be
nominated for US
Senate in Arizona it's almost a goddamn
guarantee that she'll
lose she's still talking about two
elections that happened two cycles
ago instead of running the race she's in
now and she's going to continue to do
that stupid [__] listen to them booer
listen we don't agree on everything but
one thing we do agree on is the
elections in Arizona are a corrupt mess
can we
boo she's not at no Democrat event here
there ain't no [__] Democrats in that
room trust me okay there ain't no people
who want to be associated with a bunch
of [__] fascist like the Republican
party that are gonna go in that room
[__] no I mean there might be a few
Commandos there might be a few plants in
that room I mean we got to get the crowd
going right
this kind of pretending I'm talking
about we got to pretend like there's
some people riling up the crowd to boo
her ass in that room oh there is we we
uh we talked about it our last Sunday
Swifty meeting our our antifa Sunday
Swifty meeting we talked about it last
week before it happened we're like yeah
we're going to recruit some people to go
boo Cary Lake um Taylor even said it
Taylor said it out loud yeah Taylor
wanted to make sure that people were
going to go boo and Carri Lake and get
them all rounded up I was there I
listened to it I listened to her say it
I mean you know you can believe me or
not believe me whatever whatever you
want
but oh my God keep going with the
booing are a mess in Arizona you get it
okay
yes and I know that more than anybody
and president Trump knows that more than
everybody this election is about making
sure that our elections in 2024 are run
fairly and there's not anybody in the
country who's better at that than Jus fa
that is why I Endor her and presid yeah
I endorse the the Maga candidate so that
way because what they're doing is
they're they're selecting a chairman of
the Arizona National or the Arizona
Republican party
here that's what they're doing in this
room and Carrie lake is trying to get
get the the chairman of the Arizona
Republican party to be a certain person
that she wants so that person will just
make her the [__] us candidate
because they want to subvert all
elections right I mean we've already
seen it out of the RNC where where the
the fit and all fear her Grandpa
shitler decided it be a good idea to get
a hold of the Republican National
Convention committee and make sure that
they just made him the presumptive
nominee and then when it didn't work
when it got scrutiny he was like no no
that wasn't my IDE
wink as he gobble up more
Aderall what do you want from me he's a
[__] drug addict Trump is a goddamn
drug addict and a
rapist he is he's an addict and a rapist
and I know we're not supposed to mock
addicts but I don't give a [__] anymore
I'll mock him for
it it's the point I was trying to make
earlier yeah we probably shouldn't be
making fun of addict but him you goddamn
right we'll lean into
it Aderall
adol the fentanyl
furer the morphine
monster what do you want I mean we can
keep going Grandpa shitler Grandpa poopy
pants the Cheeto dust Qin
honor rapist diaper boy yeah I mean that
that describes him great rapist diaper
boy listen I know it feels like that's
not what's going to win but that's
what's going to get America's attention
if you if you go out there and call him
the fentol F people like why are you
call why are they calling if we get that
going the fentol here I don't know
[__] hashtag it on
Twitter hashtag that [__] on
Twitter someone write me a really good
tweet and I'll post it on my [__]
account with that hashtag and we'll get
that hashtag going when the country
finds out oh why is he called the fear
fentol fearer well cuz he's a [__]
Nazi and he's a drug addict is that what
you want in the white house huh is that
what the [__] you
want I know it sounds
stupid but that'll that'll [__]
that'll work better than trying to
[__] trying to normalize this idiot
in the media trying to determine what
his border policies are going to be his
border policies are going to be to
[__] Deport people and put people in
camps that look and and sound and feel
like anyone he wants to put in
camps he's going to murder people he's
going to kill people like he did in 2020
when he was deric in his [__]
duty when he killed millions of people
because he wouldn't get with the truth
and the facts about covid and about the
pandemic yeah you can get eight off at
all eight off the trending too get that
hashtag going someone write me a tweet
and I'll post that [__] and we'll get it
going
again this is the kind of good trouble
that we could cause yes we got a small
Coalition here but it's big enough that
we will be heard and we should be just
as loud and just as dumb as Maga I know
I know it feels like that sounds crazy
but it'll
work it'll
work just like the entire country
these meal team is all worried about
Taylor Swift because the Chiefs won a
playoff
game I mean it doesn't make any sense
but none of this is supposed to make
sense hell even with this border [__]
speaking of the Border
stuff it doesn't even make any
sense but that doesn't mean they're not
going to talk about it I mean here's the
lieutenant governor of Texas the
lieutenant governor of Texas who damn
well knows what the hell the [__]
is we have a right when the federal
government we believe under the
Constitution we believe it's our right
to protect our people pure and simple
and to protect our country the federal
government is not doing it that was part
of article 4 section 4 when the United
States was founded by the states we
created the government they had a deal
to protect us against Invasion now
Invasion protect us against Invasion I
got agree retweet here hang on what's I
tweet this stuff I want to show you this
process here let me show you this
process might as well since we're taking
a master class and how to [__] with
these people all right here's my Twitter
account I'm just going to go tweet this
thing all
right uh we're going to copy paste out
of
U out of
um Discord here and we're just going to
make a hashtag here so you got the the
fentol fascist
right and we can do the fentol furer too
should we do that one should we do
fentol fascist or fentol
furer what should we do or should we do
both of them you know that's a good idea
all right we'll do the fent all fashist
here fur's got the mark on it though
doesn't
it does it have the mark on it do you
got to put the over the over the U that
might be a little too much you know what
I mean that might be a little too much
for a for a
uh I don't know here hang on here let me
show you this because fur technically if
we want to get and again we can pretend
this [__] you know what I mean here
here's here's here's where you got to
pretend because fur actually has this
Mark over the U you know what I mean but
we ain't going to use that [__] we ain't
going to use that [__] we're goingon to
we're going to take it just like that
and we're going to go back back to here
and we're going to
um this is how how you build tweets
paste and then we're going to take fur
her and we're going to paste it there
paste look at
that the fentanyl fascist just just came
in his pants he was like cream of
mushroom
soup [__] I don't care post that [__]
there we go all right now it's live on
Twitter so now we got these hashtags on
Twitter the fentol
fur oh it's it's someone already came up
with this [__] there it is the fentol
fur is liveing well what about the fent
and all fascist well fent and all
fascist is brand new that's the only one
fent and all fascist so get it go to
Twitter go to threads go to Facebook I
don't care where you're at start the
hashtag fent and on fascist or fent and
on
fur we can get this [__] going if we get
this [__] going people will question it
be like whoa what the [__] does that
mean and I'm not talking about people
who know who know the news right that's
one thing that that left is getting
their brain about [__] they think just
because they read it on Twitter and
they're following the issues on Twitter
means that the entire country they are
not paying attention Okay that's why
when I say people need to st stop doing
videos on every single little Court
motion and they need to get with
messaging and narrative stop doing a
goddamn video on every single [__]
Court motion so you can make money with
the ads okay I get the grift I get it
and there'll be plenty of time to grift
after this election there'll be plenty
of time for you you'll be able to grift
all day long if you want with your
YouTube account and your Twitter account
Jesus [__]
Christ right now we got a [__] we we
got a battle to win and that battle is
the Battle of
mockery um we've got um here's the
mushroom soup apparently that was um
there's the mushroom
soup the mushroom soup from the fentanyl
fascist this is what it looks like when
you uh finally come on fentanyl I guess
I don't
[Laughter]
know
this is um this is the Warfare that we
need because we got to fight these
[__] [__] like this [__] down
in Texas
yes are we making fun of trump but yeah
but this guy is standing up this guy
[__] supported Trump BEC after Trump
supported making sure that that [__]
Nazi attorney general that crooked ass
criminal attorney general down there in
Texas Ken Paxton stayed the Attorney
General this son of a [__] [__] did
that these [__] [__] listen goe
go ahead you piece of [__] Joe Biden
wants to argue what inv is eight million
people who have come into this country
illegally murderers molesters terrorist
rapist rapist eight million rapist eight
million terrorists what you you mean you
mean eight million Donald Trumps is that
what you mean eight million Donald
Trumps have come into this country is
that what you're saying Dan Patrick huh
is that what you're saying 8 million
Donald Trumps have come into this
country rapist
terrorist huh criminals corrupt [__]
is that is that it 8 million Donald
Trumps have come into this country
because that's what I hear you
saying because we all know that Donald
Trump is a goddamn domestic
terrorist and we all know that Donald
Trump is a goddamn rapist I mean he's
been adjudicated for
it hell he's been he's been [__] he's
been [__] charged by a grand jury for
trying to overthrow our government and
stealing top secret documents sounds
like a goddamn terrorist to me sounds
like a traitor to me I mean I know a
[__] when I smell one and most of time I
know a [__] terrorist a traitor and a
rapist when I smell one especially if
they've been found to be that in a court
of
law this how you do
it this is how we need to go after this
fool no holds bar that it's [__]
like Trump's in big trouble because of
this motion in court today let me bore
you to death by telling about this
motion in court that ain't going to make
a hell beans worth of difference in the
long run this will have some Financial
in fact he's a billionaire many times
over could argue that he can afford this
but can he afford now to to listen to
his lawyers advice who are going to say
don't say a word about he's going to
want to say a word
about keep
going keep going adal adol keep going
fent off F keep talking keep spending
money keep doing it and you keep talking
to you [__] [__] Dan Patrick keep
going gang members drug dealers car
jackers kidnappers drug dealers you mean
like Ronnie Jackson in the White
House do do Aderall Adolf huh you mean
like
that that's invaded and by the way oh so
we're invaded we're invaded when we get
drug dealers in the White House
apparently that's what Dan Patrick
thinks we were invaded by 8 million
Donald Trumps in this country eight
million Donald Trumps have come into
this country godamn
it rapist terrorist drug addicts oh my
God eight million eight million Donald
Trumps have come into this country what
the [__] are we waiting on what the [__]
are we waiting on we need to get the
military down there to the border to
shoot and kill every single Donald Trump
that crosses the country all or the
line I don't know I think that's what
he's saying ain't that what he's saying
that's what I'm hearing him
say is that 8 million Donald Trumps have
come into this country
criminals rapists drug
addicts right
[Music]
thieves it's what he's saying 8 million
Donald Trumps coming to this country and
what does Dan Patrick want to do he
wants to make sure that the states can
defend themselves against these 8
million Donald Trumps coming into this
country maybe he's on to something I
don't know huh
maybe proper mockery is sending all of
them here who's getting paid for it here
but armed cartels armed cartels like
maguga yeah that's right armed cartels
the armed cartels that are going to go
down the border to try to fight the
United States
military morphine musolini thank you
Anita there's another one there's
another one baby morphine
musolini oh God I gotta [__] tweet
that [__] now hang on a second hang on a
second hang on a
second hang on don't don't go
anywhere we gota we got to do the proper
mockery
here here let me show you let me show
you need
R there we
go go [__] go tweet that [__] post
that [__]
boom you keep going I'll keep [__]
making them known let's see is there any
other ones just me just me on the
morphine musolini go spread that [__]
around like it's [__]
herpes go spread it around like you need
a goddamn penicillin shot on the
Internet it's not of this [__] not of
this light gloved
[__] not for this snowflake ass [__]
where we get offended [__] that
[__] because Dean Baker is Right Dan
Patrick is one of the most deplorable
human beings ever that deplorable son of
a [__] he's the one that went on the
[__] national news on Fox News during
the pandemic and told us America told us
Americans that we should just not worry
about old people in this country that
they should give their they should give
their [__] lives
give their [__]
lives for this for the sake of immunity
in this country [__] you man [__] you
Dan Patrick you piece of [__]
trash stand there talking about how
criminals and rapists are coming in this
country when this [__] stands up and
supports the [__] criminal and the
rapist who just got he just lost $83
million to EEG Carroll because he won't
shut shut his [__] rapist criminal
mouth are they going to be turned off
fighting him continue to insult the
woman and getting a 20 to30 million
fine Captain bankrupt is what he is like
Justin says here Captain bankrupt I'm
telling you we we there's not there is
not an end to the
nicknames opiate
oligarch just coming chat make sure we
save this chat by the way today we got
to save this chat to today and we got to
analyze all the drug nicknames in this
chat I I'm I'm sure we got a tool in the
laboratory that can uh analyze this chat
and get all the drug nicknames and
figure out which ones are the best
ones
[__] morphe musolini that's a good one
that's a damn good
one
but I'm telling you all this sh all this
mockery and this [__] will roll
downhill because frankly when Dan
Patrick here is sitting here
dehumanizing people wanting to come into
this country to make a better life for
themselves because that's what he's
doing the problem is not people crossing
an imaginary line at the border that is
a distraction that is a distraction from
what the actual problem is and the
actual problem is Republicans like Dan
Patrick
that's the [__]
problem they won't put pressure on
anyone who can fix the problem to fix
the problem and then when someone wants
to fix the problem they say no we don't
want to fix the
problem and dehumanizing [__] women
and children and migrants coming into
this
country that want to be American that
want that want the American dream that
we're told about all the [__] time to
demonize and dehumanize them is [__]
vile and I'm not going to sit here and
be offended any longer I'm going to do
something about it what I'm gonna do
about it is I'm gonna Mock You Dan
Patrick you piece of
[__] so yeah I don't think we should let
8 million Donald Trumps into America I
don't want 8 million Donald
Trumps but that is not who's crossing
the [__] border you
[__] not even close
to who's crossing the
border so he can go get [__] and as
soon as we as soon as we get our [__]
together and really start really start
doing what we should do with these
pieces of
[__] and calling them out on their
[__] the minute it happens here
here's a good [__] example I don't
know who this [__] this [__] is yeah
I said it and I'm going to keep saying
that word because it gets attention
because people hate that word so [__] it
I'm gonna say it I don't know who she is
but she's running in South Florida again
she's a congress woman who voted against
the chips sacks who voted against
infrastructure but listen to how she
brags about it listen to this [__] but
watch this journalist do what all
journalists should do if we got more
journalists to do what he does the way
that he does it maybe maybe Jim here his
name is Jim maybe Jim here has been
listening to [__] Tony Michaels
maybe maybe just maybe he's got that
[__] of attitude that seems to be rubbed
off on [__] James Carville I think I
don't know if James Carville has
listened to the Tony Michaels podcast
are heard about the rustling ball the
left but I have a feeling the [__] a
attitude is where he's
at but Jim here also has no [__]
patience
for the cousin [__] fascist that want
to take credit for what they voted
against listen last month you were at
FIU and you presented a check for
$650,000 to help small businesses at FIU
but you voted against the bill that gave
the money that you then signed a check
for and handed and had a photo up the
Consolidated Appropriations Act of 2023
right you voted against that bill
[Music]
I this is how you do
media oxycotton
oligarchy no seriously we need to save
all of these all these need to be saved
they all need to be tweeted and they
need to be hashtagged and tweeted and
memd okay we need to put all of them on
memes I don't care who you you need to
go to Discord if you have the ability to
make something or make it up go post
that [__] in Discord go join Discord
it's [__]
free it's [__] free listen I'm
telling you right now this is how we
organize go to ttony michaels.com click
membership she can be a member of
patreon that's free too if you want to
be a paid member that helps keep the
microphone on that's how I get paid
mainly is patreon that's how I get paid
is you contribute each month to this
show and I get paid and I can keep
yelling and screaming and keep
organizing everyone to cause [__] to
save our democracy but Discord is free
you should join the book club too that's
where we're going to talk to Rachel
boffer about her book on [__] her
books her book is that's coming out soon
is on [__] she sended me an advanced
copy I can't wait to get it I'll show it
to you guys when I get it when I get my
Advanced cop I don't know if I'm
supposed to tell you that or not but I
don't give a [__] I may not be a I'm not
I might not be able I might not supposed
to tell you that but I'm getting an
advanced copy of Dr Rachel Rachel
Bauer's book right here and I'm gonna
show it to you and we're gonna we're
going to do that [__] in book club with
Dr Rachel bofer by the
way but go join join the Discord server
get into we can make we can make a meme
creation Channel where people can create
all these memes that we come up with on
the show to go spread
around in operation go commando because
operation go commando should be in full
[__] Force we should be talking about
it every day we should be organizing
every day for go operation go
commando we're going to engage in our
[__] democracy we're going to do it
together so all these ideas need to be
[__] saved every last one of them and
we need to throw all kinds of [__]
[__] at the wall just to see what
sticks and whatever sticks we just keep
[__] it out
baby if it's working and it's getting
the message out there we just keep going
we lean into that
[__] narcotic
Napoleon they're all
great poopy pants Pill
Popper Grandpa
clap
just keep
going and dereck's right the library of
democracy is awesome come join come join
the Discord the library democracy
sponsors the book club I'm telling you
the mighty librarian she creates content
you need to support her we need helpers
we need helpers we need people in the
Discord for
helpers to be part of operation go
commando to be part of the the meme
Legion the part of the Rat
Army that will ban with the Carville
Commandos that will ban with these other
Pro
democracy little bit they might seem
little but it's going to be a big
Coalition and that's what operation go
commando is about the simplest psycho
there you go there's another
one they just keep
coming I'm GNA
come sorry I stepped on the
uh I I stepped on the sound effects
Department
there oh
man um Deborah says we need [__] them
branded whistles I I'll try it or
cowbells yeah so if I can get cowbells
or whistles I'll put them in the one
store even if I gotta mail them out
myself I
guess I guess we can do that maybe I
maybe I can get some recruits in the
Discord that want to help me with that
um just DM me if you want to help me in
Discord
figure out the [__] whistles or the
or the [__] cow BS and we'll figure
out a way to make it work I'm willing to
do anything anywhere anytime if it's
about saving democracy it's about making
sure that these [__] crawl back
underneath their rocks I'm for it and
I'm ready and I don't care what it takes
I don't care what extent we have to go
to in the movie
Lincoln in the movie Lincoln there's a
scene with Tommy Lee
Jones um and he says in that scene let
me see if I can find this
thing um Tommy Lee Jones says there's
nothing that I may not
say nothing that I may not
say and I think it's one of the
best scripts right script writs about
our democracy that I've ever seen that
I've ever [__]
seen it's one of the best
um you guys know the movie
Lincoln
um he plays thaddus
Stevens let me see if I can find that
there is the debate and it's a really
popular one um but the one I want is
after after his speech because he gives
a speech before Congress for the 13th
Amendment now if you guys don't know the
13th amend
Amendment did away with one of the most
vile things one of the vile pieces of
history that our country has ever had
and it's
real
slavery and the 14th came next right it
was during the Civil War the 13th 14th
amendment was
passed and after that after that speech
because thaddus
Stevens had to
say something that he didn't believe
in he said something that he didn't and
didn't really believe
him and he end to
pretend and because he had to
pretend it felt
disingenuous but when he did it it
wasn't
because he believed it it wasn't
because he had conviction for
it he had conviction for the result of
what he
said he had conviction for using the
weapon of what he
said and that's the most importantance
that's the most important
part it's the most important part about
it
is that there maybe not anything that I
wouldn't say almost
anything to save my [__] democracy
for my
children my grandchildren that don't
even exist
yet and I think a lot of you would go to
the end of the [__] Earth even if you
had to pretend a little bit just a
little
bit just a little
bit and I almost bet that there isn't
almost anything that you wouldn't
say to do it play that [__] play that
[__] oh here I can play it here I got it
I got it here we go I found the
clip see if we can play
it see if it'll
play oh let's just give
me nothing you won't say I'm sorry
you're all you say said that must be
unpleasant I want the amendment to pass
so that the
constitution first and only mention of
slavery is
yeah it's not playing very absolute
prohibition this
a can you just pull the audio and we'll
play the
audio because give me a bunch of at porn
ads just give me a bunch of pornads have
you lost your very Soul Mr Stevens is
there nothing you won't say I'm sorry
you're na you I said that must be
unpleasant I want the amendment to pass
so that the Constitution's first and
only mention of slavery is its absolute
prohibition for this amendment for which
I have worked all of my life and for
which countless colored men and women
have fought and died in now hundreds of
thousands of
soldiers no sir
no seems there's very nearly nothing I
won't
say almost nearly
nothing that I won't
say
and that's the grand away that's why we
need the flavor chocolate cowbell and gr
Diva's ice cream shop there's almost
nothing we won't say to fend off
[__] like this and I hope the media
keeps with it just like he does listen
to how he [__] goes at her right now
you have to give me more details but I
do know that every time I have an
opportunity to bring money to my
constituents I do so I just did I just
did $1,000 but look you but you voted
against you voted against the chips and
science act right listen I right now I
need to I need to ask my staff but know
what don't we look at the $40 million
that I have brought to this community
aren't you proud of me aren't you proud
of the $40
million proud that I wrote the dignity
act haven't I let's talk about the
America act wait wait wait a second let
me one second tell me the money that you
talk about the $40 million that you
bring back to the district sometimes
that money comes from bills that you
voted against you voted against the
chips act and yet you praise the fact
that the south Florida climate
resilience Tech Hub is going to be
started in Miami right you voted against
the infrastructure Bill and you talk
about all the money that comes back to
the airport so at the same time that
you're taking credit for the money that
you bring back to The District in
Washington you're voting against these
projects on Partyline votes listen I
that was I think last cycle I cannot
really remember right now but just look
let's look at the Americans act which is
what I'm going to you don't want to
explain why you canot I mean right now
and I'm not trying to be a politician
there so many bills that I've introduced
that I know that bills that you voted
against that understand and but it's
okay sometimes I vote and sometimes I
don't but let's look at the positive
let's look at the $40 million that I
brought and let's look let's look at the
$40 million that I voted against to
bring and I want to brag about it and he
doesn't let up and we shouldn't let up
this is exactly how the [__] media
should treat every single one of these
[__] [__] every time they're on
some [__] boob tube somewhere and I
don't give a [__] at their name as Joe
Scarboro or Jim I don't give a [__]
that's how they need to be [__]
treated treat us like we're [__] dumb
like we don't know that you voted
against this [__] or even if people
don't know that we can't point it out
she's like don't are you proud of me are
you [__] no we're not [__] proud
of you you [__]
[__] we elected you to go [__] work
for us you did the opposite and then you
come here and you brag and you [__]
brag you [__] brag about [__] you
didn't do and the [__] you did do to for
us not to get the [__] that you're
saying you wanted us to
get it's
time it's time we force these son
[__] and it's time we do our work
even if they won't do it we'll do it for
us we'll do it for them we'll do it for
him but I'm glad to have Jim here Jim
here on the side of [__]
sanity and he's pissed he's [__]
pissed because this person just sitting
and lying to
constituents lying he's pissed off and
he's got [__] a attitude and he should
keep going just like you should keep
going just like we're gonna keep going
every single [__] week day every
[__] last one of them we're going to
have [__] from the beginning to the
end all too [__] hours noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific every [__] one
of them two [__] hours full of
[__] so come join the [__] that's
what I'm asking come join the [__]
come join patreon come join the Discord
server and let's get operation go
commando in full
force and let's band
together and let's engage in our
democracy and let's find these other
small coalitions that will engage with
us they're there and they believe in it
just as much as you and
I and there is nothing that we or they
won't say to save it same time same
place tomorrow surf sub
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podast in your
face commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at@ the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass speaking
uh when all of this started it was a $5
million fine and that was
it if you add everything
up including the 18.3
million the 5 milon
origin we're looking at dages in this
defination case eclipsing 83.3 shut
up million silly woman
hey Maga it is me your favorite fraud
guess what I'm gonna need you to band
together to make America great again I
don't know if you heard but King Maga
here just lost 83 million and I am close
to losing another 400
million America is hurting for donations
and needs to help pay for all my
losing